[Music]
parking
hollywood bowl yeah it sucks why are we
still here
just to suffer
leaving that place how long did it take
you to get home not that long because we
parked in like some random garage in
hollywood nice because all the parking
lots were full so we waited two hours
to not get into the parking lot so then
we just went to hollywood and we're like
we could have just taken the other
[__] way yeah and it would have been
fine yeah so we just ended up parking in
like yeah like a parking garage in the
middle of hollywood which by the way is
beautiful yeah
tell us about it
just like a lot of like meth scabs yeah
someone put a cigarette out on your
[__] forehead yeah you're walking by
yeah yeah in a wonderful place yeah you
can really feel the energy and the magic
there it's so wild when you go from
central hollywood to like west yeah just
that hard switch yeah this is that line
yeah right in front of the the tcl is
awful dude yeah they have all the you
know that's right yeah it's like right
where i parked you walked from the tcl
to it's like a 20 minute walk i thought
it'd be longer but yeah oh not tcl sorry
the the mall what's the mall uh
there's a movie theater in it
oh like right where the the bowling
alley is and the w is at and the um
yeah yeah i think so yeah no the w is
right there vine street no you're from
canada it's okay
yeah oh right there yeah yeah yeah yeah
no tcl's like way down you know who i
saw
joe
writer joe
joseph carnegie
no no i just thought you might have been
[Laughter]
like you've been trying to get one over
on me buddy
you know what i saw actually ds
[Laughter]
these
these nuts joe
joe mama
what's up joe if you're seeing this
somehow how is he he's good he just saw
uh he had just seen dune which i also
watched did you watch it no i'm gonna go
tonight i think
yeah
wow cody moved by a cinematic film
that's how you know it's good beautiful
you sat through the whole thing oh yeah
dude in a theater no no no
[__] beating it bro come on into a
theater i was about to have so much
respect for you bro then you just
[__] fell off dude i watched it on my
phone
on the couch just like
damn this movie rules
so beautiful with [__] airpods
watching in 480p
on [__] two bars of lte
damn this movie's beautiful yeah my
wi-fi doesn't reach into my kitchen so
it was kind of shitty at some points but
man yeah i watched it while i was making
a shake such a good movie dude
for two and a half hours
like that aussie clip
damn this movie's beautiful
that [__] is on fire
no i was playing among us the whole time
no it was sick i loved it i really loved
it i didn't know what the [__] was
happening yeah i still don't understand
it yeah i was going to read a synopsis
about it i think i'm actually going to
read the book now so that's what a lot
of people said and and actually my
production says and alex he said his dad
was a fan of the book
and he saw the first dune and it was
upsetting because of how shitty it was
and he said this dune is exactly what he
imagined when reading the book oh that's
awesome yeah so
it was totally different from anything
i've ever seen did you watch blade
runner 2049
yes
with harrison
a new
harrison these nuts no it's different
from that okay cool that was good that's
like that's like cyberpunk isn't it like
neon light future yeah this is more like
it's more cold it's a lot of like
dark grays and like deep blacks but then
you have that contrasted with the
[__] harsh redness of the desert and
then the glowing blue eyes of the fremen
are like so unbelievably beautiful i
can't even really describe it it just
makes her what you fall in love with
zendaya yeah yes
i was gonna say is everyone did is this
movie gonna have the avatar effect where
people watch the avatar and they're like
i can't be an avatar i'm gonna die i
wanna [__] have you i wanna [__]
avatar that you know avatar was just
like one
big movie of like a small man feeling
love as a tall man yeah that's what that
whole film was a little man becoming
tall and actually being loved yeah
because she knew it was on the inside
and she loves him for him yeah
in a tall man's body i can't wait till
we can do that yeah when they create
that knee surgery yeah no hot guy mech
warrior suits for little guys so when
you get up in the morning you crawl
inside your hot guy suit well that's
what the metaverse is for
now i want it for real it would actually
be kind of funny if mark zuckerberg was
like picking his own avatar but he was
just a foot taller
perfect just arrow
button to the top it's like
someone called us old for saying click
the sticker like when we were in the tap
what yeah instead of tap when we were
promoting the moment house show they're
like way to age yourself dude click
i'm like clicking's not outdated man
gamers click yeah you can still click
things
i have a little mouse that i plug into
my iphone right here
so i can actually click the sticker have
you heard about this fetty wap
yeah yeah yeah what did you see how
crazy is that [__] if you guys don't
know fetty wap got arrested at rolling
loud
for for on like drug charges right so i
heard that and i was like what do you
have wheat on him or something like that
yeah
uh he
and some others were charged
uh with plans to distribute more than no
they did distribute more than 100 kilos
of cocaine heroin and fentanyl and crack
like
that's [__] insane so wild
so wild bro that's 220 pounds how many
cups of coffee is that
[Laughter]
you see logan paul slapped that kid no
drunk logan paul right about it's right
about here right about here
what's gonna happen right here
yeah where is this are you gonna fight
him what's up logan
decide
for the homeless car for the homeless
come on
oh
[Music]
do you know how close we were to getting
who's sugar gay
we were right there
if logan was down bad at this point we
would have got it yeah it would have
came full circle yeah who's sugar guy
who's a [__] now
also this is outside nightingale plaza
club in l.a oh in la okay sign for the
homeless crew are you a [__] or what
what the hell
the whole that interaction is funny yeah
who's sugar gay yeah would it just you
know history repeating itself maybe we
could have ran those videos side by side
it would have been beautiful you can
tell he was like in the midst of posting
that to a story too he's looking at the
phone like i was sick
about a click and then he gets whipped
around what are you a [__] yeah
no he is not that's why you got to talk
[__] about someone on your podcast dude
you don't talk [__] to him to their face
yeah jeez
you